alésia les pierres parlent le site
archéologique se révèle grâce à une
application de réalité augmentée une
tablette confié aux visiteurs leur
permet de visualiser la cité comme l
était il y a deux mille ans on voit
vraiment ce que c'était comme nous on
est profane donc on voit des pierres on
voit des lieux mais on ne voit pas
exactement ce que c'était ici on a
vraiment une vire une vue réelle de ce
qui se trouve à ce temps là oui c'est
vraiment en plus à plus incroyable parce
qu'il permet de mieux visualiser à quoi
ça ressemblait il faut que ça apporte
une vision beaucoup plus précise de ce
qui se passait non c'est très
intéressant et on était déjà venu avant
que n'avait pas encore les tablettes et
c'était pas du tout la même expérience
là je trouve que on est plus immergé
dans le dans le truc le muséoparc
d'alésia investi cent cinquante mille
euros dans ce système ici pas de volonté
de faire dans le cas de jet mais une
réelle envie de rendre l'expérience du
visiteur plus complète et plus
enrichissantes
c'est pas qu'une question de mode je
pense que c'est ça qui est important à
garder en tête c'est que c'est un vrai
outil d'accompagnement et surtout c'est
ce sont des outils qui doivent être
évolutif il va y avoir des fouilles
encore prochainement sur le site demain
peut-être que le reste de ces fouilles
vont nous permettre de faire évoluer le
contenu de la tablette et c'est ça la
grande chance il faut surtout pas figé
ça dans le temps 10 ans c'est bon on al
houthi hop hop c'est fait au contraire
il faut les utiliser comme des outils
qui peuvent nous aider à faire
progresser la recherche et à la rendre
accessible au grand public
le muséoparc envisage d'ajouter un jeu
d'aventuré de type escape game sur les
tablettes au mois de juin et des travaux
sont prévus dans l'exposition permanente
en septembre pour présenter les
collections gallo-romaines d'alésia